[Music]
you think it's here's something else
that you had were covering a long time
ago isn't it funny now that every they
have to now they have to talk about
ashley biden's diary they have to they
have no choice but to because now it's
out there and they're not even denying
it they're just arresting people for it
i totally agree with you and
take project veritas they didn't publish
the diary they gave it to the police yep
and then somebody else published it and
then they get raided by the police have
you seen the video now if you try to
protest in ottawa the capital canada
they beat you up and slam your head in
the ground like it's north korea
and that just reminds me of this famous
pulitzer prize-winning photo this
pitcher won the pulitzer prize in 1960
shows a priest giving the last rights to
a cuban farmer owner of his land he
refused to hand over his land to be a
slave the castro regime after a
four-minute trial by shane ovar he was
executed
oh yeah it is and trust me i know all
about that i'm cuban and my whole family
is right
so um we we know very well like that
that's that's why one of the things that
obama did one of the sneakiest things
that he did was in his last day of his
presidency
he took away the dry land policy from
cuba which had been around since the
soviet days which gave citizenship to
any cubans that came here and the reason
he did that was that's right everybody
else could come here from afghanistan or
wherever child molesters but oh my god
if you're from cuba sorry well you know
why because cubans vote republican
that's they just do they
and many people that come from commie
countries tend to vote republicans like
i'm not going to turn this place into
that
yeah cubans don't even like the idea of
social security yeah no seriously we're
nuts man
hey you ready for governor matthew
mcconaughey you can see that they're
grooming him right
i can't stand matthew mcconaughey
i mean look it's very suspicious they
had a 77 minute stand down even the head
of the state police says there's a
cover-up right the head of the texas
state police testified last week i
played the clip like five times anybody
can pull it up and said we've been lied
to we don't know what happened
and the the police chief of the school
who's now the city council member won't
talk to the feds of the state police he
ordered him to stand down for 77 minutes
no one knows what really happened so but
we're not supposed to question that no
you're not supposed to actually
mcconaughey
i'll go ahead and tell you a matthew
mcconaughey's story
um
i live in austin
and i've been in some richard link
letter films
and i never tried to get movies but rick
so lester puts me in some years ago
so i know matthew mcconaughey and i've
run into matthew economy and i have uh
hung out with matthew mcconney
and
matthew mcconaughey i'm not mad at
matthew mcconaughey that he is a raging
cocaine addict at least when i've seen
him i mean we're talking massive amounts
of cocaine people say i'm on cocaine
because i have energy i take downers
like alcohol to not have more energy
maggie mcconaughey
could snort more cocaine than tony
montana
and the reason i raised that is
he's running around banging all these
chicks he's running around snorting all
this cocaine the character he plays in
willful wall street that's matthew
mcconaughey so the reason i raise that
about him is he's totally controlled
i'm not mad that he's a poonhound i'm
not attacking him he's a grown adult but
he snorts all that cocaine but he wants
to tell me as a gun owner it's my fault
somebody else used a gun wrong that
everybody knew was about to attack and
nobody went after nobody stopped and so
he wants to blame me as a gun owner that
i should turn my gun in when he's got
guns he's got private security and at
least last time i heard he is a he looks
better now but five years ago
for the last 20 years drug addict
matthew mcconaughey he is a assuming
that was not true a drug addict and so
they know he's a drug addict and they're
blackmailing
alex that was
amazing by the way i i don't know
backstage like i don't normally kiss and
tell
i've been backstage at the moody center
i've been backstage at austin city
limits six seven years ago and
matthew mcconaughey was running around
like a chicken with his head cut off
and he wasn't hiding what he was doing
so i mean i'll testify to it my point is
stop blaming my guns koked
leave me alone
oh i agree with it you know what you're
right [ __ ] yeah oh my god taking my guns
away okay that's amazing well this was
this this has been the highlight of my
month yeah i know this is amazing
matthew mcconaughey is literally an
actor just like zielinski what he is an
empty piece of [ __ ] yeah
no offense though hey no offense but
well no no no listen listen yeah i
listen he's an empty piece of [ __ ] i
mean that with all due respect listen i
don't talk [ __ ] about you know listen
i'm no i'm no sunday school boy okay
and like i'm friends with mike judge he
he's not a sunday school guy the point
is is that we're not trying to take your
basic right to self-defense
and so the thing is he crossed the
rubicon like i've almost attacked him on
my own show but i just i'm like
you know i'm covering other topics like
to crash the dollar and human animal
hybrids i'm not going to do it but i
mean next time he's having an event i'm
going to go bullhorn his ass matthew
mcconaughey is not a texan he's a joke
and he's an enemy of america
i would love nothing more than to you
show up in in your in your basically
infowars tank and do that to him because
that's the thing they got somebody and
by the way the matthew mcconaughey thing
and i'm sure you know but the matthew
mcconaughey thing has been something
they've been building for a while like
oh he's the new bill clinton oh yeah
yeah
he's the ambassador to the world of
texas according to ut yeah and he
literally says alex
you shouldn't be able to have a gun no
one else should be but me i mean he's
like i'm i'm worth 500 million dollars
alex and no one else can have guns with
me and alex it's and and and all you
guys it's your fault there was a mass
murder at this school and i'm like dude
if my next door neighbor kills his wife
and the police come and say it's my
fault i say get the hell out of my house
you're blaming me for some psychotic
person that killed people and you want
my right [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you matthew mcconaughey [ __ ] you
man you goddamn drug addict
you blackmailed piece of [ __ ] meth head
[ __ ] you
you know
and honestly he says he doesn't really
talk about it on his show i'm glad you
used our show to say it [ __ ] matthew
mcgregor no
i was never a huge fan of his either
we've been saying i found him really
stiff in a time to kill he's a drug
addict junkie
no it is yeah that's why he goes well
you know they're also stand by while our
veterans far for our right to keep their
arms while he takes a big [ __ ] [ __ ]
on it get the [ __ ] out of texas and go
to california you piece of [ __ ]
you know alex you're right and i think
this is this is that trying to turn
texas blue thing that they're doing yeah
they're trying to position him he's
going on he's going to erode
to rape the state of texas because they
got him by the balls
he goes down before they blackmail him
for his drug addiction and everything
else he's involved in i will destroy
makani long before he gets to that point
i love it
no i was just saying that like you know
you notice he's doing all the podcast
appearances oh yeah yeah and he's trying
to do this whole like uh blue christian
thing you know what i mean where it's
like yeah man like i'm a christian i'm
into the bible and stuff and i also like
you shouldn't have a gun and like you
know usually like just just these weird
like like they're trying to friendly you
know the best part about high school is
girls say the same age i just get older
that's a really good point and you're
saying he was a method actor yeah oh he
me
listen let me tell you something half of
that word
we're not gonna sit around while matthew
mcconaughey torpedoes our second
amendment that launched this country in
so i've sat back
when i have seen him running around like
a
maniac i mean we're not talking about
just a normal drug addict he is a
elvis presley level drug addict and so i
mean i'll give him this he's herculean
like i have trouble getting out of bed
when i drink a half bottle of vodka this
son of a [ __ ] could snort a pound of
cocaine and go to work the next day
well yeah any
gallons of whiskey just i mean
we're i've i've seen him use cocaine
and i've seen him drink gallons of
whiskey i've not seen reportedly he's a
meth head
so he's a meth head actor
not a method actor
just uncorked all this look out this is
great now you are you kidding me this is
wonderful we hate matthew mcconaughey
we're pretty open about that i mean
matthew mcconaughey and also the dan
crenshaws
matthew mcconaughey is a hemorrhoid on
the acid texas
there's some real beef there a big giant
pulsing hemorrhoid so you're not a fan
of a time to kill
not a big kid no not a big time to kill
fans i don't think so look all i know is
all i know is my [ __ ] family founded
texas and i'm an american patriot and
when and the son of a [ __ ] wants to
come out for my guns he can burn in hell
also
it's no secret he's a degenerate drug
addict also they want to come for your
guns i know i've killed zero people with
guns royce has killed zero people with
guns
how many people have you killed with
guns
nobody so really alec baldwin has us all
beat alec baldwin
shot two people and killed one with a
gun yeah so maybe these guys need to
stop telling me what to do because i
have multiple guns i've never killed
anybody oh my god no no
no
no no
it's just like when adam lands at sandy
hook shoots people or harrison kleibold
at uh
columbine or or or this guy in uvalde
when you when they shoot somebody you're
guilty so i want to tell both of you
guys revenge of the sis
you are guilty
for
what alec baldwin did and i want you to
say you're sorry as gun owners
that you
apologize
as gun owners for him shooting the
director and the camerawoman apologize
now cause that's how much sense this
makes in fact i will apologize as a gun
owner that alec baldwin shot those two
people well i will apologize and only
for the fact i'm really sorry that it
wasn't supposed to be a suicide scene
mm-hmm
that's me that's what i feel about it
and that's acting and i'm allowed to say
that's just the internet
yeah i want to apologize
to stephen baldwin
because i was kind of making fun of him
for a while when he was doing his
christian skateboarding stuff
you've you have now made it to the top
of the bald world you're now the best
baldwin stephen baldwin i think so my
only apologies go to stephen baldwin is
the good bald one yeah i know stephen
baldwin he's definitely a har he's real
it's not an act yeah i he's grown on me
over the years he's he's now the best
baldwin yeah because he's at least he
stayed consistent that's an official
decree
it ain't hard to be the best house in a
bad neighborhood
you know alex my favorite thing about
alec baldwin is that even the shooting
thing is when his wife pretended to be
from spain that had to be one of the
funniest things that's ever happened are
you the white girl from boston how do
you say cucumber i'm like oh oh oh you
liar no i mean they're obviously totally
fake people but i'll say this alec
baldwin in glenn larry grand ross he's a
great actor i mean i think he's a great
actor but he's also a piece of [ __ ]
yeah
he has bodyguards he doesn't want us to
be armed
[ __ ] you man but is he a great actor all
his best roles are where he plays a
piece of [ __ ] i feel like he's maybe
he's just a really good piece i think he
just shows up and dresses nicely and
then yells at the salesman well i'll
just be honest i'm just saying he i like
as an actor i think he's very watchable
but i'm saying as a person he's a piece
of garbage
no it is matthew mcconaughey is not good
in most his roles he's a bad actor
unless he's playing a pedophile and
here's the message
matthew mcconaughey
jesus told me to take you down
oh no
oh no matthew oh no matthew oh god oh
god uh don't worry he can't hear you
he's probably face down and second face
down in the puddle satan pops up on this
shoulder yeah that's madonna he's good
be nice to him alex he's good he wants
to take the guns and he loves bill
clinton huh
he a little angel mcconnell he's bad
bring him down
destroy him yes yes
you know
i i didn't have alex jones starting a
holy war with matthew
mcconaughey i'm on my bingo i'm this
week i am here for it man but if i did i
would have had bingo no but i mean i i
get it though because man look at what
happened how how much how much you're a
total sake oh yeah absolutely but how
many of those people seriously i've seen
him i've only been around him three
times he was so bombed out of his brain
each time he didn't know where he was
you know i believe it i i really i
really do believe it
i mean if you met me the three wrong
times you know you might get a bad
impression yeah but you're not trying to
take my guns away marsh that's true
that's the difference one time he had
cocaine all over his face
so like a cocaine mustache
man i'm not do you look like he was
making pizzas
the only reason they're pushing him is
because they got him by the balls yeah
well that's the only reason they push
any of these people control me because
listen
i ain't screwing no dudes i'm not using
cocaine heroin anything illegal i admit
i like nicotine and alcohol damn it
and i mean and i go home to my wife
every night and they don't have but
somebody like him and they got him by
the short hairs
yeah i think like any time they get alex
it's always like some minor thing that
is relatable that we all know we all do
like like having like a uh having like
some kind of screaming fest in a
steakhouse and you're like okay yeah who
hasn't been there i've been there
i've been there many times any human had
anything they have they have files on
these other people they're like banging
kids they're like going to secret
satanic rituals and then they're like
all right we finally got someone alex
what well he was yelling at some guy at
a steakhouse looked like he had a few
drinks like okay so like every dude ever
after the guy came to my table three
times and said i'm gonna kill you yeah
oh no i know i know he was starting it
but it was just that was a great clip
was when you were just like
you're gonna get [ __ ] with me i'm
like dude why are you starting with this
man do a lot of people bug you do a lot
of people actually bug you in in public
like when you're just out hanging out i
would think austin's pretty chill right
for the most when trump first got
elected
no exaggeration i went to uh hawaii for
a week and a half and did some business
stuff and i would shake it was so crazy
like literally first time in my life i
had like 30 40 people around me
particularly the hawaiian like signing
autographs it was like elvis stuff but i
would still get the fu russian spy or fu
sandy hook thing but like one out of 500
people but if you go back four or five
years ago when trump first got elected
i would try to like go downtown that's
kind of like la and austin so the rest
of it's pretty much normal but downtown
is like la worst part of l.a now we get
f.u russian spy for russian asian
none of that happens now which is a
bellwether of the rest of the awakening
so no i uh
i might get walking to the airport like
a
fu scumbag
in between 400 500 hands i shake it i
shake my hand i take the selfie because
i love the fans like oh sorry i'm a fan
like hell i love you the reason i'm
still on there please help me more this
is the website buy something you know
i'm like no i love you like please shake
my hand please take a photo uh i love
them more than they love me but you'll
get to screw your family or screw you
thing i don't even care about that but
it's very rare now
uh and so that shows there's really a
big awakening because i'm like a
bellwether the average person
you know is just a regular guy or
regular lady they don't realize what
you know what's going on or they're not
recognized so they don't understand it
but believe me
i've gone from one out of a hundred
negatives to one out of a thousand and i
i'm not bragging it's just a great
testament
so i rarely buy my own dinner you see i
rarely anywhere in the u.s california
new york
uh florida i mean help florida got a
little bit of the west coast of florida
and you know stay in in some of those
areas south of tampa i'm thinking about
moving there
and
and i mean i literally get mobbed